[Music]
four years ago I was basically
unemployed
Wanderer with no home
but now
I'm a husband and a father
and I wouldn't have it any other way
and I did it pops
my job was a little less stressful than
yours
oh yeah I finally got a job I'm the king
of Atlantis
half a billion
peep every known
to call this place home
but that doesn't mean they don't like me
I'm gonna kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds dear
I'm gonna murder his family
and burn his kingdom to Ash
he must be stopped for a global meltdown
is imminent
I think I know someone might be able to
help us
fool you look rough
do not call me brother
but I cannot believe you let this happen
you know well I hate this job true king
built Bridges right
two King builds Bridges
we need to find Manta he's different now
he's stronger than before
the black trident
during King outland's time there were
Seven Kingdoms
upon them all
the kind of start magic is spreading
he means to end the bloodline
[Music]
I don't know what I said but we can't
leave our children in a world without
hope
you're not as bad at this as you think
if you lead
the Seven Kingdoms will follow
[Music]